thank you everybody for coming
um this is incredibly exciting panel uh
when i got invited to moderate it
uh i was really impressed
i said
i'm gonna moderate them
this is like you know they invited the
monkey to run the zoo
um
but but here i am we've got uh
incredible panelists um we're gonna go
um
john weiner
has dreamed all his life
of a panel that went in reverse
alphabetical order
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to go and reverse alphabetical
order except
that john dean wants to go last so he's
going to go out of order
um
if um
turn off your cell phones
okay
um
john is is a genuine intellectual he
writes about
history and and
he writes for new york times magazine
new republic his new book is
historians in trouble if there is ever a
cable station for intellectuals this
will be the desperate housewives
um
no it's true it's true i mean the first
the first historian is like this demon
witch that you know like that that evil
female korea woman that always shows up
in hollywood movies
and except in this book she get um she
it has a happy end she gets appointed to
a high administrative post by the bush
administration
um
not the one who married the vice
president
let's see um
science friction which is michael
sharma's book
um michael has been a defender of
rationality for years and years and
years
uh he's the publisher of skeptic
um he's the guy who came out with the
idea of calling people who actually
think brights
and
he's also the author of why people
believe weird things how we believe
the science of good and evil
and
what i think you know kind of what i
think is going on here the title of the
panel is deceit something in deceit's
deception and cover-up
so
you know john john's new book is dealing
with historians and this is a field in
which
accuracy and accountability and being
able to prove what you say are the gold
standard that's what you're supposed to
do
michael's book is about how we
not not so much his current book but his
previous books are about how people
believe and why they believe and why
they believe in stupid things which is
probably the the um
the most important issue in america
today
um
[Applause]
um
most of you know i mean
uh there there is a paper on the east
coast with a name really similar to the
one that sponsors this festival
um
probably every literate person in the
world has read that newspaper and i
assume you're all literate because
you're at a book fair so
in that case you've all read maureen
dowd
you know
who's been you know right there on the
scene with bush one bush two and bush
two and a half and
um and she also has a pulitzer prize
okay her book is bush world
there it is
bush world enter at your own risk
and um
okay eric alderman media critic
[Applause]
eric is best known for what liberal
media the truth about bias in the news
and in which he proved conclusively that
maureen dowd is actually a conservative
[Laughter]
his new book is is when presidents lie i
thought the subtitle was going to be
when their lips move
but
but but the subtitle is um
a history of official deception and its
consequences
and the consequences now seem to be get
reelected
and which it was which it was under
nixon right
and um
john dean
i think everybody knows who john is
john is the only republican that i'm
aware of that turned into a really good
writer
[Laughter]
he's he's also he's his current book is
worse than watergate
and he is also the author of lost honor
the rehnquist choice a biography of
warren harding and blind ambition okay
john in reverse alphabetical order go
for it
well it's a it's a real uh honor and a
thrill to be uh sitting next to john
dean and on a panel with maureen dowd
let me tell you who larry beinhart is
larry beinhardt's new book is the
librarian but uh but this this is the
man who who wrote weg the dog this is
the man who wrote wake the dog
anyway uh i'm i'm interested in
um
why it is that when
academics professors historians are
accused of misconduct
that sometimes they end up on page one
and find their careers ruined and
sometimes they end up appointed by
president bush to important offices
uh historians uh have been in the news a
lot lately and the news
has not been that good
you may know of ward churchill the
ethnic studies professor at colorado who
the governor wanted to fire for his uh
outrageous statements about some of the
victims of 9 11. maybe you heard about
middle east studies at columbia where
professors there have been charged with
abusive treatment of students
i i'm interested in
talking today about
two cases of
research misconduct by historians one of
which resulted in a career ending and
one of which resulted in a bush white
house appointment and i want to start
with the
the latter uh
the current national archivist of the
united states now probably most of you
don't care too much about this but john
dean cares about this and i care about
this
the current archivist is a man named you
should carry you should care thank you
thank you uh he's a man named alan
weinstein he was nominated by uh
george bush and uh took office just uh
last month
um
he has written he's a scholar a
historian of soviet espionage in the
united states
and he has been charged with
research and misconduct in
his two most important books
the most recent one is called the
haunted wood it's a history of soviet
espionage in the united states that's
based on the um archives of the kgb
but what alan weinstein did was he he he
and his publisher
paid uh for exclusive access to this
archive they paid a hundred thousand
dollars to the kgb retirement fund
and in exchange for the hundred thousand
dollars they not only got access to the
documents but they got exclusive access
which means no one else is allowed to
see
the documents that they cite now this is
not only a bad idea for people who
wonder if alan weinstein quoted the
documents correctly it's also a
violation of the code of ethics of the
international association of archivists
which says the principle is that
documents should be uh open to uh to
everyone
so
the job of national archivist
the national archives is the place where
the official secrets of the united
states are kept
and
the public we we of course want to know
as much about our government as possible
because of course democracy depends on
an informed electorate and presidents
all have secrets democrats as well as
republicans have secrets so it's the job
of the archivist
to
represent the public in its quest for
information about what government is
doing
access to documents is what this job is
about but
the person that george bush appointed to
be in charge of the secrets to be
representing us in our effort to find
out information about what the
government is doing himself has a record
of paying
archives to keep their documents secret
from his own critics
this seems wrong
but it's not the first time he's done it
his previous book was called perjury
it's a history of the alger hiss
whitaker chambers case which was crucial
in the
beginnings of the of the cold war and
that ca that was a a
a book based largely uh on interviews
and um
it came out almost 25 years ago
in that book the
um
it was considered to have provided uh
conclusive uh evidence that algerhis was
guilty as charged of uh spying for the
soviet union in the 30s and 40s
but the editor of the nation magazine
victor navaski a person who eric
alterman
writes for regularly and i write for
intermittently
uh did a very simple fact check he got
in touch with the first six people
interviewed in the book asked them if
they'd been quoted correctly and they
all said no
100 of them said they'd been
misrepresented misquoted or otherwise
their position had been distorted now
everyone who does interviews knows that
often the people you interview are
unhappy with the way their interviews
turn out in print it wasn't what they
uh hoped for it wasn't what they thought
you were going to do it happens
so this doesn't mean that alan weinstein
is necessarily wrong about this but the
way to do it and he knew what to do he
said he would make the tapes of his
interviews available
to victor navaski the nation magazine
and anybody else who wanted to see them
that was in
1980
to this day no one has ever been allowed
none of the critics have ever been
allowed to see those documents only the
friends of alan weinstein have been
allowed to see those documents now while
this seems a bit deceptive it's also a
violation of the statement on standards
of the american historical association
and of the uh
the association of oral historians which
says that oral history documents are
supposed to be made available to other
researchers as an appropriate at an
appropriate archive like the ucla uh
oral history archive the columbia oral
history archive
that's what he was supposed to do he
knew he was supposed to do that he
promised to do that he even signed a
deed of gift alan weinstein did that he
would deposit these at the truman
library in in missouri
truman library never got them
so here's a guy
it's almost as if the white house said
here is a historian who has spent 20
years stonewalling his critics he's our
kind of guy
and that's the man that's the man who's
in charge of the official records of
of all of us of our government
now the contrast i want to make in the
minute i have left
the opposite the opposite fate michael
beliel wrote a book called arming
america it's a history of gun culture in
the united states it argued that
americans had fewer guns
in the
late 18th and early 19th century
than historians had previously believed
this
was taken to be a significant argument
about gun control today although i'm not
really sure it has much to do with
whether there are too many guns today
but there were serious questions raised
about his documentation
unlike alan weinstein
michael bellio provided his critics with
all of his documentation he gave him all
of his materials told him what archives
he'd been to turned out he'd screwed up
a lot of this there was a lot of errors
in what he did
a distinguished committee of historians
concluded in fact that he was guilty of
fraud in one of his tables and he
resigned a position as tenured professor
of history at emory university now what
if michael beliel historian of gun
culture in america had done what alan
weinstein did had refused to share his
archival documents had refused to make
his materials available to other
scholars there would have been a
tremendous outcry why was it why was it
that the
critic of the of the gun lobby had his
career ended
while the person with ties to the
republican white house had his career
advanced and why was it that the stories
told in the media about this
were that michael beliel was
guilty of research fraud
while no one seemed to care about the
questions raised about alan weinstein
except for eric alterman and me actually
uh
and victor and victor who's on another
panel at this hour
i conclude that the right has been much
more successful than the left when it
comes to cases of charges of misconduct
by historians the right has been able to
reward those it considers its allies and
punish those it considers its enemies
and that's all i have to say about this
michael
you're up next
okay
good morning how we doing
i have to stand up for this
i'm going to do a psychic reading so you
have to stand up for this
i am michael schumer the director of the
skeptic society and the publisher of
skeptic magazine we investigate claims
of the paranormal pseudoscience fringe
groups and cults and claims of all kinds
between science pseudoscience
non-science bad science voodoo science
junk science non-science and nonsense
and as you may have noticed there's a
lot of that out there
some people call us debunkers but let's
face it there's a lot of bunk
that needs debunking
so in my five minutes i'm just gonna
basically talk about
psychics and deception because they go
together
and and then cult leaders and conspiracy
theorists and then finally the general
concept of deception as a whole so we
begin with what we do kind of like trash
collecting it's a dirty job but
somebody's got to do it and that is
debunk the psychics because it looks
like
they are able to read people's minds and
talk to the dead that kind of thing
oh i should point out anybody can talk
to the dead it's getting the dead to
talk back
that's the difficult part
and that's where the deception comes in
it looks something like this
there's some spirits in the room coming
through here just a moment
yes somebody on this side of the room
has lost somebody
they've passed over
which is convenient since i'm standing
on this side of the room and the cameras
are right here
that's how it works in these studio
audiences it's funny how the dead
congregate in television studios in new
york and los angeles
but that's you know that's the way the
spirit world works and uh
so there's somebody coming through i'm
getting something around here like a
an r name a robert or richard something
like that a father figure could be a
grandfather grandmother mother father
uncle close friend of some kind
yes i think it's you sir yes i do i do
think it's here
you were nodding in a certain way
hang on just a minute yes
he's telling me something about um
in your garage you have some power tools
that are broken that you've been meaning
to fix
right
and uh
how did i know but they told me and you
ma'am um
uh i'm being told something about you
have a box of photographs in your closet
you've been meaning to put into um photo
[Laughter]
albums you know
sir i'm getting something about there's
i see a calendar on your wall a calendar
it's an out of date calendar you've been
meaning to take it down it's an 04
calendar
most importantly you ma'am i'm getting
something about how you're
a thoughtful intelligent good
communicator with a good sense of humor
you're shy sometimes but at other times
you're outgoing
all right why would anybody fall for
this kind of shtick and i'm not i'm not
particularly good at it i don't do it
very often if i did it a couple hours a
day like the pros
you know you'd get much smoother at it
and it's because people want to believe
that it's true it's a confirmation bias
you
look for and accept confirmatory
evidence which you already believe and
then you just filter out uh all the rest
that doesn't fit you remember the hits
you forget the misses
so if i were to do an actual reading on
you did you used to wear your hair
longer when you were younger by the way
and there's something about an earring
you've got
you you have a you have one that you're
missing the other and you're hanging on
to it because you're hoping to find
there's a whole book of this stuff this
kind of spiel you can use all right so
are these psychics deceptive
intentionally i'm not sure
i think for sure some of them are that
is they are out and out con artists
fraudulently deceiving the public to
make money that's true but that's not
very interesting to me that's just like
a street con what's more interesting is
the possibility that they've
self-deceived they've convinced
themselves they can do this because with
practice they've gotten better at it and
better at it and you the people coming
for the readings give them positive
feedback which makes them more confident
and the more confident you are the
better you get at it the more convincing
you are
to your clients who then are ever more
convinced you're real and feedback on
that and that's why i think most cult
leaders
are not out in our
con artists i think they believe the lie
and if you believe the lie
then your body and face does not give
off the cues
of line so
sort of wrap it up here i think there
was
an evolutionary arms race in the long
history of of human evolution between
line and line detection
i think we're pretty good liars and
pretty good lie detectors
i think the liars have a slight
advantage over the lie detectors unless
you spend a lot of time with somebody
and then you can collect enough data to
have a sense that they're trustworthy or
not
and so i think when we encounter
somebody once
they can get away with the lie
you can you can buy into the deceit when
you interact with somebody a lot it's a
lot harder to do it because they start
giving off those subtle cues and there's
interesting research on this now about
facial expressions and cues that we give
off
you know when you when you look at the
camera and say i did not have sexual
relations without a woman
missiles and you think this guy is
really good
but you know he's lying all right so
um if with enough exposure to that
individual it becomes clear there's
something off there there's something
untrustworthy okay why would that be
and i think so this is sort of where i
wrap it up with the science of good and
evil book on
how
this all evolved that we evolved as a
social primate species in these small
groups of a couple of dozen to a couple
hundred individuals in which shunning
and other informal social means of
behavior control work just fine to take
care of the liars deceivers cheaters
outliers that the frauds and so on we
can deal with that fine when everybody
knows each other and those kinds of
people through much exposure get exposed
and so on what happens when societies
get large populations get into the tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands it's
too easy for the the outliers to hide in
the nooks and crannies of a large
society and that's why i argue this was
the birth of religion and government
about the same time state societies and
large religion religion is a form of
behavior control it's a moral behavior
control it's not just that we're going
to shun you it's that you're not going
to get away with it because mr big is
keeping track and but even that's not
enough because there are some people who
don't care if mr big is keeping track so
we have to deal with them in the here
and now and that's what you need the
state for and that's how we got to where
we are basically in seven minutes thank
you
maureen are you ready for this
um
well
can you guys hear me
yeah
um i didn't know i was supposed to
prepare something so i'm going to be a
little inarticulate here but that's okay
because even when i prepare i'm
inarticulate so
you're not going to notice the
difference
my favorite quote about washington is um
one that russell baker
said in his memoir which was that
covering washington was just a matter of
sitting in ever grander marble halls
waiting for someone ever more important
to come out and lie to you
and um
i grew up in washington and um
my brothers were capital hill pages in
the 50s and you know they uh their job
was mostly to you know when senators
would get drunk they'd get the brass
spittoons you know they'd they'd
you know step into them and not be able
to get them off their legs and my
brother would have to pull it off or
when their wives would call
you know different senators and um
they'd be in their hideaway offices with
their mistresses my brothers would have
to keep the wife from coming so
i never actually grew up thinking
washington was um
you know a totally
um pure plays but um
my dad was uh
a police detective who was in charge of
capitol hill security and he would judge
politicians um by whether they were
phony or not and he was born in ireland
and his favorite phrase was you know
they're full of prunes
so
and i think i took that on kind of as an
ideology because he he would never
mention their party he would just say
they're a phony or they're not a phony
so um
when i wrote bush world i uh
you know i i wished i were evil and why
because only he could do justice to the
story which is um to me one of the most
amazing it's it's like a heist story i
call it ocean's 911.
because
[Applause]
although wolfowitz is no brad pitt
believe me
[Applause]
um because these guys took all of our
emotions and fears uh that we felt after
9 11 and
diverted them to a plan that had been in
the making in their heads for a decade
at american enterprise institute and it
was kind of a perfect storm they all had
different reasons for it but it was not
what they told us it was
a threat to our imminent security so now
it's we're in a very interesting ends
justifies the mean situation now and i
uh have seen enough shakespearean plays
to know that um
enz justifies the means usually ends up
with the body littered with the stage
littered with bodies at the end of the
play so i'm very skeptical about that
but everyone now is saying you know what
wasn't bush right and don't you
shouldn't you apologize to wolfowitz
weren't they right and to quote um my
friend and and uh fellow columnist
richard cohen
it really i i don't want to be
i'm not at all churlish if things go
well in the middle east i'm thrilled you
know for the sake of our country and the
middle east and our troops who can come
home sooner but i don't really care if
democracy spreads from the nile to the
tigress it is not going to change the
fact that lying to the american people
and ginning up evidence and turning you
know all of our institutions into um
you know distorting them to distort
truth for an ideal ideal ideological
goal is right and it's never going to be
right to tell the american people
um to not tell the american people the
truth about why you go to war or the
families or the troops so i would never
change my mind about that
um
you know i as far as just random
thoughts about washington i mean it's
it's just a remarkable time there
because what we're watching is
the um republicans trying to turn
america into a theocracy while the bush
administration desperately tries to stop
iraq from becoming a theology
which is one of these great circular
things in the same way that bush 41 went
to war with saddam in iraq to establish
the principle that one nation can't
unilaterally invade another
and his son went to war with saddam and
iraq to establish the principle that one
nation can unilaterally invade another
so um
uh
republicans are better
uh hypocrites you know they they just
have a gift and a talent for it
as the nuns would say when i was little
they're just great bold brazen pieces
and they um you know they can just say
more outrageous things and then the
democrats uh won't have a hard time
calling them on it because they say well
free speech or something so um
you know i came across a flyer yesterday
um
that says that bill o'reilly is going to
be leading a
you know on a cruise a love boat kind of
cruise in november
and
it's called a values for america cruise
and here's the part i love it's to the
caribbean
which is exactly what he he got in
trouble on the phone fantasizing that if
he were with this girl in the caribbean
you know he could liquor her up and live
for her so
so now he's on a values cruise there so
it just proves that republicans are
geniuses so
anyway thank you very much
[Applause]
um thank you
uh you know uh
to pick up on something maureen said uh
at the beginning of her remarks about
how uh those of us who um
didn't think this war was a good idea
for any number of reasons
appear to be on the defensive now
for whatever reason to me this is
another example of how incredibly
effective the right has been at
controlling the political discourse
i got a
gallup poll emailed me to me on tuesday
i got them every tuesday morning
and this gallup poll demonstrated that
53 percent of american people think it
was a mistake to go to war in iraq these
numbers have been consistent for the
past four months the previous uh gallup
poll i got the week before before that
looked at george bush george w bush's
popularity ratings and uh compared them
to previous second term presidents at
this point in their second term and he
is the most unpopular second-term
president at this point and second term
since gallup began doing the polls and
over and over we hear about this popular
president persecuting the successful war
and that those of us who warned against
it because of what things that later
demonstrated to be true are supposed to
be on the defensive and that's i mean
that's they've won the game when you
when when they've controlled this course
that effectively because you never get
to the actual
problems that that that they've caused
it's all it's all you know it's that's
just that's going to do with anything
except
i got the mic here and i
um
last night i i spoke in a synagogue in
irvine and i started talking i i picked
up this story that i had read to my
daughter in the about the bible
recently and there was a rabbi there and
i hassled him about that story and it's
just i i gotta
i gotta come a little bit prepared to
these things because
thoughts pop into my head and i and i go
with them a little too long and we've
only got five minutes and i haven't even
mentioned this book here you know
um this book that i wrote uh
about presidential lying called when
presidential i think so i noticed you
didn't hold it up the first time
um
uh it's not a book that's um it's not a
book that's actually morally preening
about lying it's not a book that says
lying is always wrong
uh
my i tell my my daughter's actually here
she's got her headphones on so she can't
hear me which is a good thing
because i tell her that lying is always
wrong but the rest of us
should understand that there are times
in in our lives
uh you know if if if your wife really
does look fat five minutes before you're
you're supposed to go to a dinner party
you have to lie more seriously
um
you know when when huck finn and and and
and jim are on that boat and uh and
there and the gyms owners are up on the
cliff and demand to know from huck is
his uh
is his companion white or black and huck
uh
and huck lies and says white that's
that's that's a noble lie that's the
life-saving lie i can't imagine
uh anybody who would think that huck
would have done the right thing if he
had sent jim back into a life of slavery
and degradation merely for telling the
truth emanuel kant argues
that if there's a murderer at your door
with a gun and he says where is my
intended victim i would like to go kill
them now
you have a moral obligation to tell the
truth
because if if you lie then you become
responsible for what happens next and if
you don't lie then it's not your problem
i like to think emanuel khan wouldn't
really tell the truth in that situation
i like to think he's just being cheeky
with us and that's his
very fancy way of doing so
but
um it's true uh
uh as we heard at the beginning that
most presidents do lie and they lie with
pretty
a considerable degree of regularity i
actually i think that george bush's lies
are the least of our problems i mean i
really don't think
george bush lied any more than believe
it or not franklin roosevelt certainly
not more than lyndon johnson and um john
dean's friend what was his name again
the thing about the bush administration
is not that they lie it's that they have
a contempt for the truth which is
something different um
roosevelt
the book is set up to be a pragmatic
argument for truth in other words
roosevelt lied about yalta john kennedy
lied about the deal that settled the
cuban missile crisis
lyndon johnson lied about uh
the gulf of tonkin uh situation he
didn't lie on the day of it he lied a
few days later when he found out the
truth and ronald reagan lied uh about
everything he ever said about central
america
um and that all of these presidents paid
a pragmatic price for having lied that
they all would have been much much
better off had they simply told the
truth to the country and bitten the
bullet at the moment but none of them
roosevelt was quite sick at the time he
died six weeks after he gave his speech
about yalta so that might be a special
case but i had
none of them had the sort of small form
of political courage that would have
been required to tell the country an
unpleasant truth at the moment and so
they ended up finding themselves in a
web of lies which is actually when you
think about it quite natural because
once you if the president tells a
consequential lie about something then
he's got to keep lying because
presidents create their words
and create a reality and that reality is
separate from the reality that they were
originally talking about so they end up
dealing
with the lies rather than with the truth
meanwhile the truth comes back to bite
them in the ass because
reality doesn't go away so in each of
those cases each of these presidents
paid a significant price uh roosevelt
and kennedy were not around to pay the
price anymore because they uh they both
died but their parties paid the price
and they would have paid the price had
they stayed in other words it was a bad
political move
seen in the long term and i think that's
organic in the system of the ecosystem
of lying in politics
but i think what's happened is that um
we've gotten too used to lying even
though like i said it's not always the
worst thing in the world we've gotten
too used to lying and
because our political system has ceased
to
uh hold uh presidents to any standard of
lying that we don't even really pay
attention to whether or not what they're
saying is lying or the truth it's all a
question of whether or not it it smooths
the workings of the system
uh that uh that the bush administration
has has taken uh
this this insight uh and it has
metastasized it
and so it's not simply that george that
you can't believe what george bush says
is that you know that i was i think uh
listening to your presentation about how
it's scarier that they believe what they
you know it's more convincing but it's
also scarier that they believe what they
say then it isn't i mean in some ways i
would feel better about the world if i
knew bush knew we were lying
um
but more significantly it's that it's
that the truth is is it's not simply the
lying it's that the truth becomes
irrelevant there's a quote in my book
and i use it in a cover story i wrote
this week in the nation about the attack
on the media from michael kinsley that
this administration they give the
impression of that the fact that they
lie because they can't be bothered to
tell the truth if they told if they
could if the telling the truth were
easier they would do that it's just too
much of a hassle but the
seems to me who's really at fault here
are are the media
because the media come back the next day
for more lies they're quite aware that
they're being lied to i mean just last
in the last week there were two very
significant pieces of legislation that
went completely under the radar having
one having to do with mercury emissions
uh setting the standard for mercury
images another one having to do for
nuclear storage in the yucca mountains
now these are complicated issues and
intelligence i don't understand them all
that well but i do know that the
administration suppressed the studies
that they themselves had commissioned
because those studies did not
demonstrate what the
administration wanted to show which was
that hey it's okay to do whatever we
want to do in the first goddamn place
now those studies the the people who
come who who who
made these studies scientists both
inside and outside the administration
put themselves on the line and said hey
no this is not the case if you remember
you can you can pick almost any issue
you want where this happens same thing
happened with that when they rewrote the
medicare issues where they had they shut
up that guy who said he'd be fired if he
let happens over and over and over again
okay and they denied that these studies
existed at first and then they denied
they said they didn't commit whatever
they would over and over entirely
unbelievably and the story disappears
okay the story disappears in part
because it's not that sexy in part
because it doesn't involve michael
jackson and small boys or there's no
little blonde girl to get bulletins on
every night
in other words part of the problem is is
tabloidization part of the problem is a
lack of attention span on the media but
part of the problem is they just won't
stand up to this administration and and
say damn it we're tired of being lied to
we're not going to accept that standard
we landed this business very differently
i'll stop there
mr dean right
uh the reason i wanted to go last is i'm
not sure why i'm on this panel
now these these people all write about
uh lies deceit and cover-ups uh so they
are secondary sources i guess they put
me here as a primary source
and and as a primary source i sort of
looked over this panel and and
got to know a little bit about them
i knew some of them beforehand
certainly i knew maureen who i've been
reading
since before my hair turned gray but
remarkably sure hers is not and she
looks younger than ever
and i know larry's work and i must say
that
do yourself a favor google his name
go to his website
and look under his multimedia files for
something called war on as in war on
drugs
war on poverty
and have a treat and larry i must say i
didn't know about the war on
masturbation
[Laughter]
i was also thinking as i pulled up my
seats being
attracted to attractive marines
i'm not real glad that this is being on
broadcast on c-span my attractive
maureen might wonder where i'm sitting
today
eric i know
because i had the pleasure of reviewing
for the washington monthly
his win president's lie i also happen to
read his dissertation which he is the
first part of the book and he's the only
guy i've ever met in my life who has a
phd in presidential line
so so after i after i read his
dissertation i wondered if stanford
passed those out for real life
experiences as well
michael i must say that your your work
why people believe in weird things
i've always suspected because they were
weird people
but
it was something of an epiphany for me
so i uh last night pulled it off the
shelf and opened up to the the moment i
remembered in reading the book where i
saw probably the most perfect
description of the white house staff i'd
ever read and i'm not talking just about
the staff i was on but uh those who
proceeded and followed me which i've had
a chance to study let me just read the
bullet points from this section on page
119
veneration of the leader
inerrancy of the leader
omniscience of the leader
persuasive techniques hidden agendas
deceit
financial and or sexual exploitation
absolute truth absolute morality well
he's not describing a white house he's
describing the elements of a cult and
i'm afraid that michael is an awfully
good description of most white houses
that's scary
a little scary
john i know because i've had the
pleasure of doing his radio program on
kpfkfm on a couple of occasions
and it's a it's unusual talk radio it's
unusual in the fact that it's actually
intelligent talk radio
so
he and i as he said do share
our concern about what's going to happen
to presidential records after this
presidency leaves something i've written
at some length about
in my worse than watergate book
what i'm hoping john might get into
today is a piece he wrote some years ago
that stuck in my mind back in uh
in the mid 80s late 80s where he found
the real
uh
nancy davis
and not nancy davis reagan a rather a
nancy davis who was flipping hamburgers
in ventura county and had been the
purported reason that ronnie and nancy
got together
uh
well he kind of put the lie to that
story and i'm hoping he'll share how he
found her and how he put the light of
that story today because it's
fascinating
that this woman says she was never a
communist
she threatened that uh if
nancy davis reagan kept saying so she
was going to sue her she stopped saying
it for a few years then she resumed
again and it's of course become the
official myth of that presidency and and
the uh
the media of these people
so i guess
i'm here
obviously
to provide
fair and balanced coverage
[Applause]
i think what we're going to do is find
out if we have questions for each other
and if we do we'll we'll talk a little
here and then we'll open the microphone
in the middle there for questions from
you
um
um michael
i have a question for you okay so here
we are
we have a a administration that as
maureen said is where we're turning
trying to turn the country into a
theocracy
um
and it's always been my sense that the
only difference between believing in
weird cults and
or actually i i read a psychiatric
definition that the only difference
between
a delusional belief
and an acceptable belief like a religion
is the number of people who believe in
it
um
this is your your area of expertise
so my question is
how do we separate out what is
delusional
and what is a sensible belief and why
why has
delusional belief become
an acceptable
uh standard today i mean
there was the study of the people who
voted for bush were all deluded about
what he what he believed in what other
people believed in and whether they were
weapons of mass destruction and so forth
wow
i knew you were going to say that right
[Laughter]
so turn on your telepathic powers right
now
um
yeah well that's a mouthful gosh there's
a lot there uh issues that we deal with
separation of church and states
obviously a big one for us um
specifically with things like attempts
to teach creationism in public schools
which has a political
and religious agenda behind it and
the current administration's uh sort of
emphasis on on faith
how do you tell the difference well
that's what science does better than
anything else and this is why i'm such a
pro science guy is because
as deeply flawed as it may be and
conducted by humans who are subject to
all the same biases as everybody else
like the confirmation bias looking for
the hits and ignoring the misses and so
on it has a self-correcting machinery
built into it which requires you to look
for your own misses and mistakes and
biases because if you don't
one of your colleagues with great glee
will point it out
and so in that sense science is also
very competitive and uh it's one of the
reasons i trust the system it's not a
faith in science so much as it is
confidence from its experience of being
so productive and useful and
good at what it does
that it it is the best system we have
for telling the difference between these
things and whatever the particular claim
is the problem is when it's
loaded with say religious or political
implications then it's harder to get at
it so
for example recently i was disturbed by
this
observations when michael crichton's
book state of fear came out the same
week that jared diamond's collapse came
out
and it was very predictable i could tell
already what the reviews would say based
on who wrote it and where the review was
published i didn't have to read a single
word wall street journal of course
they're going to hate jared's collapse
and of course they're going to love
creighton's book predictable reason
magazine a libertarian magazine that i
read and like but they predictably loved
crichton's book and and were skeptical
of jared's book new york times loved
collapsed hated and said l.a times hated
state of fear
so there's something disturbing about
that
and i think part of the problem is is
that in
complicated scientific
questions like environmental questions
where the models are really complex and
there's loaded with so many variables
that it's really hard to say
then the data don't just speak for
themselves and you end up filtering them
through
these theories the theories that
themselves are loaded with political or
religious
ideologies and biases and so i
i find myself very torn on say
environmental issues and global warming
because it's not clear
it's clear that the earth is getting
warmer say for example in the last 100
years but it's not clear whether this is
a
part of a thousand year ten thousand
year hundred thousand year warming or
cooling trend that could be partially
human caused partially naturally caused
and so it's very complex
and uh that's why when you see you know
that one network has the left-wing
scientists on and the other one has the
right-wing scientists what's which which
wh why aren't there scientists with no
wings uh
oh which ones have the left wings
abc nbc cbs oh really
cnn yeah yeah they do
they do
so there um that's okay good
make you an honorary member of the
skeptics you should be skeptical of the
skeptics by the way i should point that
out so you know that in in short
uh that's the problem the
the facts don't just speak for
themselves on these heart issues
can i say marina question go ahead
maureen you you uh you covered the bush
senior uh white house's white house
correspondent um and both bush i wonder
what it's
you have a relationship with them as a
result of your work uh bush her nickname
is cobra the cobra they call her the
cobra and bush which is a lot better
than turd blossom which is what he calls
his best friend
and and uh bush senior complained that
you put him on the couch
what what do you make of this what
um
well
both
the father and the son complain about
being put on the couch if you um
ask them questions that aren't about
politics but in both cases i was just
asking i was doing a cultural interview
with both of them so i was just asking
what's your favorite movie or do you
watch tv and they would say don't put me
on the couch don't psychoanalyze me
so um they're very uh even
this president who is is all texan all
the time but they have that wasp thing
of of not wanting to be introspective
and you know it's interesting um
oh god
i know wasps are the last group you
can't make fun of but um
when eric was talking i did remember one
thing i wanted to say which is um
when i did uh ask pat elephant who's
brilliant i think to do my cover i i
started to tell him what i wanted and he
goes stop i i read your column i know
and he did exactly what i wanted which
was to to have a cover that conveyed a
different reality and that was the point
of the subtext you know that they didn't
like the reality they were faced with in
iraq where they couldn't prove you know
there was any reason to go to war so
they created their own reality and it's
interesting because ron suskind did this
piece for the new york times and there
was a white house official who actually
gave a quote that
said oh uh journalists you know you're
in the reality-based community
as though reality were something else
you know
and uh and he said they created their
own reality so it's not you know it's
it's it's way beyond lying it's like
just taking a reality and since the
president doesn't read the newspapers or
anything
you know cheney can put if he has a
fever about going to work with a rock he
can just put a filter on the information
that he gets and kandi you know
suppressed information and studies
that would have debunked things so they
suppressed everything that would have
debunked things and ginned up everything
that didn't
and the father and son
are similar in one sense i mean the son
ran away from everything about the
father the father was an
internationalist so the son had to be
unilateralist the father was a
episcopalian so the son had to be an
evangelical so you know the father was
sort of greenwich so the sun had to be
west texas and so but the one thing that
they're like in is um
uh they don't really connect words and
actions and uh
they um you know the father when he he
got in trouble for saying read my you
know lips no new taxes he didn't
understand that was a pledge he thought
that was just a line that peggy noonan
put in the speech to make him seem like
gary cooper he wasn't
[Applause]
you know and the sun is the same way and
they have this we know best we'll handle
it you the american public have not been
bred to lead
we will handle it and then we'll let you
know how it comes out and that's where i
differ with them so
john
yeah well i just would like to add a
footnote that it really expands way
beyond
the bushes themselves
the study you referred to with the
university of maryland which i cited in
my book is just a phenomenal
analysis of what's going on just the
week before everyone went to the poll
last november
the university of maryland with a
totally uh non or unpartisan
study tried to find out the attitudes of
bush voters versus carry voters
what they found is pretty startling for
example on the issue of weapons of mass
destruction they found that 72 percent
of the bush voters believed there were
weapons of mass destruction in iraq
justifying
the invasion of iraq they believed that
75 percent of the bush voters believed
that there was a tie between
al qaeda and saddam hussein
yes some of the kerry voters got it
wrong it was around in the low 20s
big so we do have totally different
realities when i tried to dig a little
deeper which the maryland study did not
do
but tried to look to see where this
misinformation is coming from i've got
to share with you a lot of it's coming
from pulpits where the ministers are
telling the flock what they should
believe and they're believing it
can i ask jonathan
by the way
a footnote to that there was a previous
study by the same
program on policy attitudes at
university of maryland about where
people get their information and 81
percent of fox news viewers believed
through all three of the lies that they
set up and only 22 percent of the people
who said that their primary news source
was either the new york times cbs news
or npr believed even one of those lies
and there's of course a direct
correlation between believing those lies
and supporting the war and not and so
you really had to believe something that
was false to support the war
um
here's my question for uh mr dean
uh
you know i i used to i played kind of a
macabre game with myself uh
up leading up till november or i guess
it was up till john kerry got the nature
of who i would support over if they were
running against george bush i would i
would happily have supported his dad
um if he had gotten the democratic
nomination
uh i would happily have supported bob
dole i toyed with myself about richard
nixon i went back and forth
um
and i'll tell you why and then i want to
be a good green candidate
but here's here's what i'm here here's
actually the serious point of my
question
um
nixon was a was a weirdo for sure and
you know he would send fred malt to go
count the jews make sure there weren't
too many jews in any one department but
the nixon administration for all of the
psychosis that manifested itself on on
those tapes
it seemed to have a real respect for
competence and they had some tough guys
and some ideologues and the same is
actually true of ronald reagan but there
wasn't a sense that uh
that everybody has to be on board with
everything and that we can't allow
anyone almost almost like kind of like
the polypepper we can't allow anyone to
speak anything that's off the
reservation at all and yet in in the
bush administration as i was trying to
communicate earlier it's not just a
simple matter of people giving the
politically convenient answer to every
question it's that across the board the
there's sort of an ideological answer to
every single matter and it's in the
justice department the environmental
department and the department of
interior in in hhs you know um and and
it's as if reality doesn't enter into
the question or if it does it's
something that needs to be explained
away which was not true of nixon it was
not nearly as true as reagan and it
certainly wasn't as true of george
herbert walker bush now i have i have
two
um hypotheses that i'd like to run by
you of what's changed and i and then i
want you to tell me what you think it is
uh and i'm not saying i'm right about
either one one is is that they didn't
have uh in your day they didn't have fox
news they didn't have this entire
right-wing media structure that is
willing to go out and say yes in fact we
have found weapons of mass destruction
and dan rather doesn't want you to know
about it and so that the whole idea of a
normative set of of facts that we can
agree on has been lost because the so
much of our news is entirely ideology
um and the second change is that
in those days there was a republican
party that was that had a multi
multiplicity of views and now if there's
anybody in the republican party who
doesn't believe that the united states
is a divinely inspired experiment by god
and that everything we do is therefore
blessed by god you don't hear much from
them in other words there's this
religious certainty that is that is
expressed and there's no one if you even
question the religious certainty you're
questioning the whole edifice um so it
seems to me that when you add those two
things together this this this
terrifying religious certainty these
people have and the fact that that
within the structure that's set up in
the constitution to keep our democracy
accountable there are people undermining
it there are structures there to
undermine it that they can get away with
a lot more than you guys could get away
with before you became such a great guy
[Laughter]
eric either subject would be a good book
but uh let me give you a quick answer
you're right there was no fox news in
fact the media
before watergate was an entirely
different media than we have post
watergate before watergate presidents
were generally given the benefit of the
doubt and assumed to be doing the right
thing post watergate they were assumed
to be guilty and they had until they
proved the negative that they were
innocent that was really the case up
until
2000 and it's sort of hung on for al
gore even during the 2000 campaign but
uh not very much for george bush from
the get-go he was given a pass
uh and there's no question that
there is a whole other element with talk
radio
and and the
the right having its chorus out there to
keep banging away on their key talking
points of the day
what's interesting is that nixon used to
complain about the fact that this wasn't
the case uh he's the one who said we
don't have enough right wing think tanks
we don't have enough uh right wing
media and he was very much on this case
and had he
completed a second term
i suspect uh some of these actions would
have taken place much sooner than they
did
so that
he was very aware of this problem and it
has changed the complexion as far as the
gop and and and the republican party but
you've got to remember where this whole
change in the party where it goes below
the mason-dixon line and finds the
conservatives who used to be democrats
who are now all republicans this starts
with
really goldwater
goldwater doing it with some success
nixon seeing the door open going through
in 68 but then being one out being
totally outdone by george wallace who uh
could far out uh uh uh
demonize and and politicize uh the
so-called wedge issues than richard
nixon could begin to
but in 72 uh nixon reached again and
brought a lot of those people into the
tent
and that's what started changing the the
complexion of the party i must say that
uh i don't think my views have changed a
whole lot but i find myself way on the
left today
as opposed to where the republican party
is so there there have been changes and
they do impact but i i would add one
other thing
that every president
has a tremendous impact on the way his
government and his administration works
if a president wears hats his staff is
wearing hats if a president has fires in
the fireplace in the oval office uh his
staff does the same it's it's remarkable
how
these patterns start and you've got a
unique situation with this presidency
and that i'm not sure who's running the
show
you've got one guy who's a salesman and
the other guy who's minding the store in
dick cheney and that really has
influenced a lot cheney might well be
open to listening to alternative views i
don't think george bush is
so that's influenced tremendously the
way this presidency operates
if we have questions from the floor uh
you got to go up to the microphone there
and i see somebody who's up there
already and uh sir
yeah hi mr dean um great respect for you
and how you've come out like you have in
your writing at findlaw.com i can tell
you exactly who's running the show with
the bush regime it's the lakutnik um
neoconservatives most of whom are jewish
as mr altman had written about in his
nation magazine piece can we talk i mean
that's right here you're
mischaracterized like to justify the
bamford book that explains this in
detail i didn't say that
on the record i didn't say that and i
wouldn't say that james i'm telling you
sir you have an article from april 21st
2003 i have it in my hand and you said
that there's a taboo to talk about the
lacunae neocon agenda
to the jewish institute for national
security affairs is there objection to
the new american century why are we
talking about james banford as pre-tech
for war book he should be on this panel
it's a disgrace that he's not and he's
never been invited to this discussion
sir or the festival
thank you
next please
i i promise not to be as rancorous
uh
it see it seems that uh the right the
right in politics today have uh at least
we've learned effectively that
consumerism and creating a product
through lying and associations and
developing a strong support system on
the on the uh religious right and other
aspects of the right have really
really nailed it in terms of how to sell
themselves and i wonder whether the left
is shooting themselves in the foot by
maintaining a kind of moral high ground
about being truthful and essentially
should they be learning how to package
themselves and are they going to be the
second party in this country forever
because they are not uh
haven't learned that lesson so is lying
okay and necessary in a consumer culture
is the issue
anybody got an answer to that
um no it's a big country you know
uh i i think i i think the trick is to
learn how to package whatever it is that
you got rather than make up something
new to have so i mean
um
democrats who aren't particularly
religious
suddenly repackaging themselves as
anti-abortionists
who pray a lot is silly but people who
have strong passionate feelings learning
how to articulate them clearly in a way
that people understand them and will
respond to them positively
is is something that i think yes the
democratic party needs to do any
disputes with that one
yeah no i was just going to add the
first the first time i really noticed
the difference i mean i'm sure it was
before this but with what i was covering
was during the clarence thomas anita
hill hearings
and it just dawned on me that the
democrats were sort of you know trying
to figure out what really happened while
the republicans didn't care they were
just playing to win and they were
throwing everything at this woman and
the two techniques were so different and
then i've just seen it played out in
every
thing since then like south carolina you
know mccain was just kind of
hit with everything in south carolina to
the point where he really
lost his breath and didn't even know how
to respond because he could not believe
how personal w had been but then in the
end
americans love winners so then when bush
wins you know he has that potency of the
winner so i think the republicans feel
you know they don't really care what the
truth of it is or what the tactics are
because they want to win and i don't
know
you know again it's an ends justifies
the means things i don't think democrats
have to
stoop to those tactics but they do have
to certainly be more muscular about how
they go about fighting
next um on the issue of politics and
religious cults i was wondering if
anybody had any insights on
why the mainstream media has given so
little attention to the emergence of sun
myung moon as a major power broker in
washington and why if you want to get
the truth you have to read weblogs and
alternative media sources the second
article i ever published in my entire
life i want i'm really i'm kind of
pissed off about this because it's the
one time in my life i was smarter than
michael kinsley
i wanted to call he called the article
in moon's orbit which is okay i wanted
to call the article bad moon rising
but anyway i wrote that article it was
in
1983 or four or five something like that
and then it was a story and people got
the story and now they've decided that
it's not important now sometimes that's
because everybody has all the
information they need and the fact that
it's not really that important that sun
young moon owns the washington times
because you know what the washington
times is and the other properties that
he owns but sometimes it's just because
the media lose interest in a certain
story and there's no way to make them
interested i think it's very interesting
that uh for instance on
on that point that yesterday the senate
approved john negroponte as head of the
democratic head of the uh the new
intelligence arm john necroponte he's
not responsible he he is we have we have
the papers on him he he was engaged in
helping the
salvadorans cover up massacres in the
1980s now he didn't he didn't give him
any green lights to have any massacres
which by the way some u.s officials
appear to have done but he knew that
they had taken place and he made sure
that there was nothing done to prevent
future massacres and stop them we have
the papers we have the memos it's all
there there's no he can't deny it and
yet it's just like it's too much of a
hassle to go into it they were fighting
bolton on the one side so john
negroponte is is getting a pass and the
vote was 98 to two and it seems to me
that there's an awful lot of issues that
just the system can't handle or that
that because the dem part of the big
problem with the debate over the war was
that the democrats couldn't be found to
make an issue of it but there's it seems
to me that our system uh and maybe
there's no other way to do it but our
system so narrowly uh chooses what it's
going to fight about that enormous
amounts are lost and for instance to me
i think it's quite significant that we
chose as one person to be the most
influential person our entire
intelligence committee is someone who
has the past of covering up massacres
you know i think that's pretty
significant problems it's the same it
seems to me strikes me as the same
principles alan weinstein being the head
archivist i mean it's kind of like a
principle that this administration has
that you find the worst imaginable human
being for a job and you give it to them
but
but again is is
where where are the media where are the
meeting
uh this is a question that involves the
whole panel because it's about lying but
uh i'm going to direct it to uh cobra
woman
um
what at this point are the chances of
judy miller heading for the slammer the
martha stewart wing of course but the
slammer nonetheless
well i guess um
according to what i read in the new york
times and uh good
chances are good she's going to end up
in the clink because uh
because the bush administration has just
kind of systematically gone after the
press and tried oh this is another thing
about the reality-based community
they've tried to replace the press it's
like invasion of the body snatchers with
their own version of the press people
like armstrong williams that are paid to
you know spread the word on on no child
left behind and jeff gannon you know a
male escort could get into the house
bulldog yeah could get into the white
house but my white house pass was taken
away so they think they can replace the
press
you know and it's a very ominous and
then the ones they can't replace they'll
go after and put in jail and the amazing
the remarkable thing about judy is she
didn't even write a story she just
thought about it so now we're into
thought police you know and it's really
scary
you know my understanding in that is
they they leak this story to six people
five of them refuse to take the story
and write about it one of them did
they're going after the ones who didn't
write the story i know you know what let
me just one at one thing there was a
decision came down on tuesday of last
week from the uh
full united states court of appeals
district of columbia who turned down the
appeal uh of miller and cooper uh
knowing that there's something that's
interesting and lurking in this whole
story though that uh
no one really quite knows what's going
on when judge hogan the chief judge uh
or excuse me the yeah he's the chief
judge of the district court held the
contempt
citations as valid and acted on
fitzpatrick's motion
he filed an affidavit and it's was
sealed part of the appeal was the fact
it was an ex-parte proceeding and nobody
other than uh
the prosecutor and the judge know what's
in this document but the judge gave just
enough of a hint he said the
investigation shifted uh during the
course of the investigation and these
are very important witnesses uh
judge hogan happened to be a classmate
of mine and a friend of mine and
actually one one time my attorney he's a
very cautious man
i can't believe he would let fitzpatrick
go off on the lark so i don't think we
know all the facts here of why
fitzpatrick feels he has to have this
testimony uh and why he's banging away
at this so there's we don't have a full
complete picture to make a judgment on
it john is there any way you can tell
this story to yourself without robert
novak having testified
uh well you know i i i think he might
have taken the fifth but why would they
why would the judge accept that why
wouldn't the judge put him in the same
position well then you have to go
through a whole immunity proceeding and
they may have thought it not worth it i
don't know uh he is obviously there are
two people who could solve this problem
one is novak two or whoever leaked the
information if they came forward and
said hey we're the leak we don't want a
miscarriage of justice we don't want
miller and cooper going to jail
and are hiding behind it that would
resolve the issue so it's just not novak
it's also the leakers who are the
cowards in this play
it's sound by time uh we're down about
six minutes here
so if we could keep the questions and
the answers to sound bites
and really
i
had a question
um
i keep believing that
george bush or dick cheney i don't know
who went first said
but george bush would more naturally say
my father got screwed out of the pre of
being
reelected this guy
saddam hussein did it if i get elected
president we're going in there and we're
going to take him out it wouldn't matter
9 11 it wouldn't have mattered anything
and somewhere i think
there's a hidden piece of paper
somewhere or something on some computer
where one of them says to the other if
you don't agree you're not on my ticket
you can't run for
i really believe they had planned ahead
of time
well i think i think the reasons we went
to war kind of a perfect storm of of
reasons that everybody had their own
reason and i think this president's
reason was partly to
you know avenge and one up his father
but it played into other reasons that
the neocons had you know in terms of
remaking the middle east and it played
into other reasons that dick cheney had
about wanting to smack somebody so that
the arabs wouldn't look cross-eyed at us
again and that america could establish
the principle of being a hyper power so
and rumsfeld wanted to prove that he
could transform the military and do
things with the smaller agile force so
everybody had different reasons and they
all interlocked yeah maureen's
absolutely right and it's something to
keep in mind not everything in life has
one reason
lots of things in life have many reasons
it may have been a war for oil it may
have been a war for strategic strategic
primacy in the middle east it may have
been a war for halliburton it may have
been a war for uh
to to because he tried to kill my daddy
uh it may have been a war because they
wanted to kick some arab ass and let the
arabs know that that's the kind of thing
they're going to get if they
maybe in any one of these things maybe
all of them
people was different things and you
don't need to identify the single reason
you just need to understand how the
decisions were reached and try to reach
better ones in the future in one house
okay
one more over here all right
so i grew up in an evangelical christian
home and what mr dean said is true
they're always on the from the pulp but
a lot of times people will say over and
over again that the left in the new york
times is out to hate they hate
christianity and they hate god and they
want to destroy destroy us so don't read
the new york times don't read that
because
they're against you
but i just want to say don't you find in
some sense well it's not hate that
they don't that it's some there's a
grain of truth to the disrespect for
religion on the left and how can
we expect people in the south or even
just people here in california who
religion is the center of their lives to
come over their side when our to our
side when we seem to not have respect
for what's the center of their life
well i think you've got to distinguish
between what you mean when you say the
left sure there are people on the left
who have contempt for religion and
they're quite open and vocal michael
schermer for example with respect to his
views
with respect with respect i mean
no but wait a minute wait a minute
michael did you say that michael michael
was cautious about that i said wait a
minute there are there are all kinds of
people in all kinds of places who
believe all kinds of things and to say
that a the new york times is the left
strikes me a is a ridiculous statement
but even so i didn't say the new
experience okay
the equation that it's frequently made
i'm not saying you made it but you did
actually go the new york times i'm just
saying the perception and evangelical
community here's my point yeah but
here's my point it's easy to pick up and
say oh look michael moore is offensive
and therefore i hate the democrats okay
but michael moore is not a democratic
candidate john kerry was and for some
reason the you can have like a jerry
falwell saying that the united states
got what it deserved on 9 11 and
and the republicans and the
conservatives somehow don't pay a
political price for that but you have
michael moore doing what many people
feel to be honestly feel to be to be
disrespectful of the country and the
president and yet that is blamed the
national media on the democratic
candidate noam chomsky wasn't the
democratic candidate michael moore was
the democratic ward churchill is not the
democratic candidate and coulter says
you know we should kill journalists as
first chance we get and yet there's no
price to be paid so i think that uh
part of the problem is our culture's
inability to make these kind of
distinguishes sure there are lots of
people on the left who have
contemplation but a lot of very
religious people on the left and and why
is why is this monochromatic picture the
one that is operating in our media's
mind
one last question here john you want to
ask john dean yeah i i want to just
point out that john dean uh is the only
person on this panel who uh
really changed his mind about american
politics over the last 30 years and it
makes him sort of a hero and as most
people
to the extent that people do change
their mind in american politics as they
get older and greater they tend to move
to the right john dean hasn't done that
and
i think that's why we appreciate him
and and i just wanted to ask
and i wanted to ask what what is his
secret well there's a
there's a maybe i can answer this with a
story there's a story about george bush
being down in crawford and out bicycling
uh and went by
and saw a little boy in the front yard
with a box of puppies and
asked the boy what kind of puppies these
were and he said they're all republican
puppies and george said nice that's
wonderful son when bicycled on a couple
you know about a week later he's
bicycling again with laura with him and
he said winkstatter says come see this
and he sees the little boy with his box
of puppies and he said son what kind of
puppies are those he said they're
democrats what do you mean they're
democrats well they opened their eyes
thank you